I don't work alone I mean that would be
horribly imprudent to go into a
situation when you're dealing with
demons or the Devil Himself alone so
contrary to popular opinion in the
movies we see about exisms we never go
alone at midnight during a thunderstorm
to a strange person's house in the woods
to do an exism you know sort of like
this
with this is not the usual setting of
okay so I have a team I always have
other people with me often it's another
priest so we're all seeing the same
thing you know
um they can speak languages that they've
never known they know things about you
or other people in the room that they
couldn't know so these are the Hallmarks
of how we would determine is this really
a demon Supernatural knowledge of things
they could not know languages they
couldn't they have not learned that they
can speak fluently and and superhuman
strength